Alyssa Milano says I give my Tesla back  I give back my Tesla I bought a VW EV I  love it I'm not sure how advertisers can  buy space on Twitter publicly traded  companies products being pushed in  alignment with hate and white supremacy  doesn't seem to be a winning business  model Hodge twins Volkswagen was  literally founded by Nazis and Hitler  and that gets 177 we didn't do her  homework and then Elon Musk laughs and  you see what happens there this is the  best part when people open their mouth  all of a sudden  um you're able to filter out through  people's bullets and this is why Twitter  is winning today and Alyssa Milano is  trying to find the smallest hole in the  world to go hiding so people can't find  her there isn't anything more  embarrassing than this if we had a dummy  of the week segment this is we this  could be the dummy of the Year segment  although there's a lot of other people  that are competing with her